we continue our journey covering Magnus
Carlson's games from the Alta box Norway
chess super tournament the blitz
tournament this is round six
immediately following our last game and
video where the world champion defeated
surrogate Kuryakin with the black pieces
Gary takes on the one and only
Maxine Bosh Ayla Grove Bishop f4 maybe
he intended on transposing into a
veresov like his games with Nakamura
should MBL had played d5 but after b6 he
takes a think and decides I'm not going
to get a varus off
so let's transpose into an unorthodox
sort of Queens gambit and let's have a
kid walk in front of our camera
completely oblivious to what's going on
around him right nothing like that
totally totally awesome 57 Knight f3 and
both sides continue making natural moves
with Bishop e2 appearing now on the
board by Magnus so this is an unorthodox
King's Indian with black having a King's
Indian but also at the ink head of
bishop normally you would criticize
white for not having the full space but
not really possible in the border that
was played and also you would normally
say that the dish one f4 is less than
ideal but it's it's also not the not the
end of the world especially given that
the position has become just a totally
sort of strange variation of a King's
Indian h3 plate with the obvious purpose
to make sure that this bishop has some
left to retreat to should black decide
he wants to try to win it here magazine
plays east six probably the person who I
really don't I'm not crazy about and
Magnus immediately kind of punishes it
would be for I think a5 was more natural
to stop b4e six feels a little bit too
much like a dubious opening at karna
Kimura would play a bullet Magnus
immediately plays before and even though
a5 appears now Magnus is able to support
his big space advantage with a free the
knight comes in to e4 again MBL being a
little bit a little bit tight here with
the pieces they're sort of wrestling
each other for squares when you lack
space it's natural to try to make a
trade and give your pieces a little more
room to operate generally this this
should be I would say about equal and I
think the evaluation of the engine would
agree with us here but potentially in
this position currently I think that I
think the White has decent
with the big space that Magnus was able
to establish here he makes this trade
immediately follows with 90 d2 with the
obvious intention of exchanging the
LightSquared Bishop which is going to
potentially further expose these squares
over here for later later operations NBL
trades and after Knight takes f3
we get our first sort of mini think of
the game here despite despite the
evaluation and assessment that the
whites a little bit better Maxime has
done what he needed to do to trade off
pieces and again play the the position
with a with a small space disadvantage
now he is able to play e5 and and seems
like a natural critical move and as I
said we're getting our first think here
because Magnus has some tough decisions
to make not even sure he made the right
decision and the game we're going to see
he played D takes e5 and the critical
tactics that occurred after that but
actually probably Bishop to g5 either
inducing f6 which is kind of
dysfunctional when you block your own
bishop or even Bishop to g3 instead were
probably better he played D takes d5 and
I think you can see from max team's body
language he's a little surprised he
takes with the knight and I think
happily as he should what exactly would
be Magnus intentions now when I'm
attacking the c-4 pawn if you're
thinking like Maxime certainly trading
here would be less than ideal as this
exchange would force the Queen's to come
off and black is in great shape but
Magnus surprised again after the Knight
takes by playing rook to c1 why is that
a surprise because as Maxime starts to
think about here the obvious
continuation that we have to consider is
Knight takes up three and then Bishop to
b2 potentially winning the pawn on a
three vaccine calculates and decides
against it but to show quickly how that
might have gone if Maxime just outright
wins upon what Magnus was probably
relying on is ideas like maybe even
Bishop h6 and then some sort of
compensation on the dark squares but
Maxine would have options to both
sacrifice the exchange or play moves
like rook e8 and after trade on a5 I
just have a hard time seeing white
really launching a mating attack here to
justify the pawn sack when this rook is
so well positioned there's ideas of
Queen h4 and there doesn't seem to be
any other clear ideas going on for white
so as we said Maxine kind of took the
bait
after rook c1 and he took on before
Magnus took back and then he didn't
continue to make a trade here he just
played the move Queen e7 and and that's
where Magnus plays what I think is the
the best move of the game to this point
he drops this knight on d4 very very
strong what you're going to see after
Maxine plays rook a2 is that Magnus
confidently starts applying pressure to
these light squares we sort of
foreshadowed might be a problem earlier
doesn't hesitate on the next move to
eliminate the night but Maxime starts
hesitating which sort of suggests maybe
he recognizes that he isn't thrilled
with this transition because the more
the piece has come off the board the
more becomes clear that either Maxime is
going to be defending a good night
versus a bad bishop type of position
here or he's regretting that he didn't
trade that night earlier maybe going for
that Bishop to Bishop to b2 line as we
discussed the knight comes in with tempo
and after Queen e6 Magnus isn't
satisfied brings the knight back to
before where it has a new goal obviously
on d5 if the knight comes in to d5 you
get a very very clear picture of why
that night might dominate the bishop the
knight has a clear target on the dark
square the bishop has none Maxine plays
rook to a3 and as as powerful as it
looks to have the rooks doubled on the a
file I think the biggest issue is that
black blacks targets and as I said white
doesn't 90 d5 comes in and after rook a7
magnus plays f4 really aggressive
intention showing that he now knows that
he's playing playing for maybe more than
just a half the point rook could be one
Bishop e7 and we see the gloves start to
come off here
f5 whether this is exactly winning for
white yet or not you start to love
White's position right you see this
dominant night versus the slightly
dubious Bishop you love the idea of that
pawn sac just to create open lines and
weaknesses against the black king and
after G takes f 5 we see those
weaknesses immediately start to come
under fire with Magnus playing rook
takes up five Hey you can't take my rook
buddy I'm going to fork in max Eve moves
the rook comes back to f1 the the
threats that Magnus has to deal with on
the first rank notwithstanding it's
really just a matter of time before he
brings the Queen over to the Kings side
and we start to
see what's going to happen to this open
black king queen dv4 is a good move and
you know the tactics are are a little
unbalanced still but Magnus is able to
find the right way to deal with this
which is sort of surprising he takes and
after the trade placed the move Queen to
g4 that we're about to see appear on the
board suddenly you realize that hey that
transition I did to open up your Kings
side wasn't just about opening up
attacking chances which there are
threats now things like Knight f6 check
and the fork but also the more I can
just trade pieces the easier it's going
to be for this night to show its
dominance in the board vaccine brings
the rook back to a 7 magnus plays g5 and
this is getting more more and more
familiar to us as far as watching how
magnus carlsen wins chess games right
this is an edge that he's just so
comfortable grinding out brings the king
up he's going to continue to bring just
the king into the game the rook into the
game and black's rook is stuck guarding
a pawn that it really wishes it didn't
have to right
whenever you have a piece worth 5 points
guarding a piece that's worth 1 point
but it's a critical one probably it's
not ideal right that sounds kind of
basic but it's true you don't want your
Brooks in those positions Maxime is
attacking now choosing rather has the
active rook that have the rook sit there
and guard the pawn but as soon as Magnus
sees the opportunity he captures it
anyway we get this check and on King up
3 Maxime has a new issue now that the
c-7 pawn is gone you can see which which
pawn is on the Knights I next right
that's the b61 so after rook takes d5
the knight comes backwards the b6 pawn
is captured and some smoke is going to
appear on the board now where it seems
to be a bit more of a race and I think
it actually is wrote to g3 check the
King retreats itself to avoid any sort
of mating net ideas like coming into e4
h3 the knight comes in to d5 and the
biggest issue now is we're going to see
that after the forcing moves finish off
the b-pawn is a lot harder for black to
deal with then the H pawn is for white
to deal with Knight to f4 checked even
by offering the trade of the good knife
for the bad bishop it's still going to
head to an endgame where white is the
only one in the driver's seat again
because of the C pawn in fact it's so
obvious layers of this level that they
simply throw in the towel here or Maxime
simply throws in the towel because this
b-pawn is is going to run up the board
and as we see now if you watch all three
videos in this series magnus carlsen is
in fine form here at the norwood blitz
chess super tournament winning this game
against Maxime around stay put put him
clearly in the lead and we have one more
video in our very fun I've had a lot of
fun doing this series with you coming
your way in a couple of days